bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en indirect du sénat pour la séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
parmi les thèmes abordés cet après midi
par les sénateurs dans l'hémicycle et
bien tout d'abord à deux jours du salon
de l'agriculture deux questions autour
de la sphère de la viande de cheval des
questions autour de la filière viande de
la traçabilité de la viande le
gouvernement sera également interpellé
sur les dotations aux collectivités
locales alors qu'il y a eu des annonces
faites cette semaine une question
également d'esther benbassa la sénatrice
écologiste écologistes pardon sur le
droit de vote des étrangers
et puis beaucoup d'autres questions dans
cette séance que vous pourrez suivre en
direct sur notre antenne à partir de 15h
mais tout d'abord avant de suivre ces
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
alain vidalis bonjour ministre chargé
des relations avec le parlement est
notre invité alain vidalis une première
petite question d'actualité autour de la
confusion qui règne aujourd'hui sur le
sort des sept otages français au
cameroun ou au nigeria est ce que vous
avez des informations des précisions à
nous apporter en ce début d'après midi
ou telecel précisons que je peux donner
malheureusement c'est celle qui ressort
du communiqué qui a été fait par le quai
d'orsay sur lequel la rumeur qui avait
été propagée ce matin elle s'avère
s'avère sans fondement c'était plus
qu'une rumeur vain puisque notamment un
ministre du gouvernement à l'assemblée
nationale
kader arif pour ne pas le nommer a
annoncé la libération des otages je
pense qu'il faut prendre la déclaration
les déclarations de kader arif ce matin
dans leur totalité il a fait une
première déclaration dans laquelle il a
indiqué sous réserve de confirmation et
il a fait une deuxième déclaration pour
dire qu'il n'y avait pas de confirmation
de ce qui avait été indiqué sur la base
d'une source camerounaise est aussi
repris par des agences de presse
malheureusement j'ai envie de dire pour
les familles je pensais
âge et à leur famille ici c'est
évidemment quelque chose de très
regrettable très bien on va écouter on
va attendre les développements
ultérieurs peut-être dans la journée en
tout cas on l'espère aujourd'hui elle
avec délice il ressort de la conférence
des présidents qui s'est tenue hier soir
au sénat et qui détermine l'ordre du
jour des semaines à venir que la date du
projet de loi autour du mariage pour
tous a été fixée au jeudi 4 avril
pour combien de temps ce débat a été
fixé comment elle va s'organiser ici au
sénat va coûter il va s'organiser
normalement c'était le souhait des de la
conférence des présidents de commencer
de quatre oeuvres il pas plus tard que
prévu quand même au départ on attendait
même dès la mi mars
à la date du 18 mars était la première
date utile c'est à dire on pouvait pas
commencer avant puisqu'il ya un délai de
quatre semaines entre l'examen du texte
à l'assemblée et celui au sénat la date
du 2 avril était nécessaire avait été
demandé par la commission des lois et le
rapporteur pour qui si on puisse et
c'est ce qui se fait faire un travail
d'auditions extrêmement extrêmement
sérieux à ce jour ce qui est prévu c'est
de siéger donc le jeudi et le vendredi
puis de reprendre du lundi jusqu au
samedi inclus de la semaine suivante et
peut-être le dimanche il faut finir le
texte bon s'il faut plus de temps
naturellement le gouvernement ouvrira
pour ce temps nécessaire est-ce que le
gouvernement va apporter quelques
modifications quelques retouches par
rapport au texte adopté par l'assemblée
nationale en déposant des amendements
coûtait rien n'y rien qui soit notable
il peut y avoir ici ou là des des
questions techniques sur ce qu'on
appelle mes derniers articles de ce
projet de loi et qui sont des outils de
coordination
mais bon rien rien de consistant de la
part du gouvernement
mais naturellement le sénat je n'en
doute pas va faire son travail
d'amendements ouais donc en tout cas un
vote de conforme par rapport au texte
voté est totalement exclure à une
seconde lecture sur les textes mariage
pour tous écoutés dans tous les cas ça
n'est pas l'objectif recherché d'ores et
déjà nous n'avons pas mis l'urgence sur
ce texte et nous souhaitons que la
procédure c'est un texte important aille
jusqu'au bout donc une seconde lecture
et on peut penser une adoption
définitive quant à l'or bleu de près ce
débat probablement aux environs du de
fermer entre fermé
15 juin voilà alain vidalis
sur les prévisions de croissance il ya
120 ans le gouvernement l'a annoncé il y
aura des révisions à venir se signifie
qu'il y aura un collectif budgétaire
dans les semaines à venir au printemps
peut-être leur a surtout une procédure
qui est des quais nouvelles et qui est
prévu par la constitution qui après
pardon par là par le traité
constitutionnel donc il va y avoir
demain les annonces de prévisions de la
commission européenne puis ensuite une
procédure qui amènera le nouveau au
conseil des finances publiques a donné
son avis donc c'est un haut conseil en
indépendant qui a été créé en france
conformément au traité puis ensuite à
une procédure de dialogue entre le
gouvernement français et la commission
pour arriver à ce que l'on appelle le
rendez vous européen c'est-à-dire au
mois de mars d'avril le résultat de ce
dialogue sur ces chiffres c'est à dire
le chiffre de la croissance le chiffre
du déficit prévisible et c'est à partir
de là que le gouvernement prendra ou ne
prendra pas les initiatives nécessaires
mais l'objectif aujourd'hui c'est
surtout de garder le cap sur le
désendettement et la réduction des
déficits mais y aura peut-être quand
même un collectif budgétaire avant l'été
c'est pas prévu pour l'instant parce que
les sommes en jeu s'il ya des des
rectifications à faire ce peuvent se
faire aussi bien à l'automne dans le
cadre du collectif normal que au mois de
mai ou au mois de juin dans la
précipitation
il n'y a pas d'urgence en la matière
vous pensez coûté à ce jour de toute
façon ni vous ni moi ne savons
connaissons exactement les chiffres on
les aura demain puis hamon se reprenait
jeudi des camps même décide de la
commission on a une idée des tendances
mais vous savez sur ces chiffres là je
vois des chiffres qui sont présentés
comme étant sur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances ce matin a
dit qu'une commenté pas si voilà qui ne
commentait pas ces chiffres
naturellement ça sera pas 0 8l à la
croissance la croissance prévu mais en
attend les chiffres de demain et de
toute façon le gouvernement fera
connaître sa position dès demain par une
conférence de presse tu me disais
économie et des finances alain vidalies
c'est ce que le gouvernement a renoncé à
réformer la constitution
le gouvernement n'a pas renoncé à former
la constitution le gouvernement d'abord
c'est le président de la république qui
a pris cette initiative là d'un certain
nombre de sujets dont il nous paraissait
qu'il pouvait être consensuel on sait
qui est en action plus compliqué comme
la question du droit de vote des
étrangers vient de mai sont plus
concernées qui aurait pu être consensuel
sur la suppression de la cour de justice
était plutôt un processus de
modernisation de nos institutions qu une
réforme profonde la gauche la majorité
n'arrive pas à trouver de consensus avec
l'opposition sur ces points là bas je
pense que c'est une question qui
s'adresse d'abord à l'opposition parce
qu'un autre grande surprise jour où le
premier ministre chargé par le président
de la république de les recevoir à la
sortie de cet entretien ils ont expliqué
pour l'un l ump que de toutes façons il
était contre toute modification qui
n'est même pas la peine de leur en
parler et puis il ya eu 1
du côté de lui des idées raid une
déclaration analogue même si hier j'ai
senti qu'il y avait des déclarations un
peu dit un peu divergentes à l'intérieur
du groupe centriste en tous les cas
c'est un peu regrettable
évidemment on a besoin on a besoin d'une
majorité des trois cinquièmes c'est le
président de la république qui
naturellement décidera de la suite de
cette initiative mais je pense que c'est
pas une bonne image de notre démocratie
mais ce cas pas des points qui
pourraient être réformé qui pourrait
passer autrement qu'en services aux
institutionnels alors exemple mais ne
l'a pas une loi organique ne pourrait
pas suffire
le conseil supérieur de la magistrature
pas du tout pas du tout ce qui est ce
qui est du domaine constitutionnelle et
du domaine constitutionnelle n'y a pas
il n'ya pas d'option là donc il faut une
réforme constitutionnelle
mais je veux encore réitérer ma surprise
que sur des questions certains disent qu
une loi organique pourrait suffire à
écouter notamment pour la compatibilité
de la fonction de ministre avec les un
exécutif local
non mais c'est ce débat n'est pas en jeu
puisque la pratique
bon si c'est uniquement ça la réticence
à sais pas c'est pas c'est pas compliqué
mais sur ce qui est quand même un peu
conséquent conseil supérieur de la
magistrature statut pénal du chef de
l'état par exemple c'est une révision de
la constitution
est ce que ça veut dire en tout cas que
le droit de vote des étrangers est
définitivement enterré alors sa trêve
définitivement enterré non
le gouvernement pour un certain temps le
gouvernement et pour le parti socialiste
est pour on n'a pas de majorité des
trois cinquièmes vu qu'on n'a pas
combien de voix votre avis à l'heure
actuelle entre 30 et 32 voilà est clair
donc on essaye de les deux de les
obtenir notre volonté certaine mais pour
l'instant cette condition n'est pas
remplie alors autres autre point le
cumul des mandats on en est où
dans la réforme dans la limitation du
cumul des mandats il ya eu beaucoup de
voix discordante à gauche ces derniers
jours oui un débat à gauche et à droite
aussi puisque vous a pas échappé s'il y
avait eu oui mais enfin il ya eu la
constitution à droite d'une association
pour le cumul des mandats ce qui est
quand même assez assez singulier donc le
gouvernement et pour la limitation du
cumul des mandats le président de la
république s'est engagé il y aura un
texte de loi qui passera en conseil des
ministres très rapidement c'est à dire
quinze jours qui arrive probablement dès
qu'on aura
l'avis du conseil d'état avait tout et
qu'on aura l'avis du conseil d'état est
aujourd'hui l'engagement du président de
la république qu'on ne puisse plus à la
fin du mandat du coût de son mandat
c'est à dire du quinquennat cumuler un
exécutif local et un mandat
parlementaire sera établie donc
application 2017
non moi je ne prenais pas cette
interprétation là le débat reste ouvert
et c'est au président de la république
de faire une proposition ça peut être
celle là ça peut être une autre date
donc ça devrait être tranchée dans les
quinze jours à venir si je vous ai bien
sûr tout le texte présenté en conseil
des ministres très rapidement aux deux
nous voilà au plus tard aux environs aux
environs de fer mars la sphère aura été
présenté en conseil des ministres
concernant la réforme du scrutin
sénatorial alain vidalis le gouvernement
présentait finalement une réforme très
limité par rapport aux recommandations
du rapport de lionel jospin
pourquoi ne pas avoir à appliquer les
recommandations de jospin il nous
semblait que dans les recommandations de
l'enad j'espère y en avait qui
normalement ne pouvait être reçue d'une
manière favorable même s'il s'agit pas
là d'une réforme constitutionnelle et on
les a appliqués en revenant à la
proportionnelle donc à partir de 2-3
sénateurs et et puis en augmentant un
peu moins ce que ce que préconisait le
rapport josmer le rééquilibrage entre
le vote du monde vivra le mode du monde
durement ces visites est très profond
des inégalités écoutez vous savez
aujourd'hui même avec cette réforme qui
vous paraît limité on entend beaucoup de
critiques comme quoi on aurait fait du
tripatouillage donc vous voyez là c'est
largement le gouvernement a été
extrêmement modérée et j'observe que
vous lui reprochez cette modération mais
de notre côté on nous critique y compris
avec cette démarche qui me paraît être
la démarche juste et raisonnable pour
aller vers ce rééquilibrage il ya
quelques critiques qui sont émises après
la nomination de ségolène royal comme
vice présidente de la banque publique
d'investissement et comme porte parole
de cette bpi alors une première question
d'abord est ce que cette nomination doit
être approuvé par le parlement
je pense pas en l'état de la situation
et parce que c'est une loi qui prévoit
les postes qui doivent être approuvées
par le départ le parlement il ne me
semble pas que ce poste là de vieux
gazeur le président a été approuvé par
le parlement mais c'est que le directeur
général également et donc ceux qui ne le
sauraient pas mais parce qu'elle est
c'est un poste de vice-président qu'elle
occupe et je veux dire que c'est pas une
nomination fait ni par l'elysée pour
être précise ni par le gouvernement
puisque cette banque publique
d'investissement qui représente aussi
les collectivités locales et madame
royal dont vous savez qu'elle est
président de l'association des régions
de france ou vice présidente va a été
nommé par cette association
les élus sont représentés dans la banque
publique d'investissement c'est
extrêmement de l'association
c'est l'association pendant
l'association des régions de france qui
l'a désigné à ce poste là puisque c'est
un poste qui revenait à ces
collectivités locales et le gouvernement
n'est pas acteur dans cette démarche
mais d'où leurs proches quand même d'une
trop grande politisation de la bpi siens
enfin si on met des représentants des
collectivités locales
c'est pas la faute du gouvernement c'est
la responsabilité des électeurs que dans
les régions de france il y en a beaucoup
qui sans josh donc c'est assez logique
quelle est l autre solution que une
banque est destiné à aider les pme dans
les régions c'est bien qu'il ya eu un
grand débat même que les régions
auraient voulu être plus représentés
qu'elles ne le sont à la fin et donc
c'est vrai gain de cause les régions sur
certains points quand même sur ses
terres
mais pas dans la tonalité si vous
reprenez les propositions de
l'association des régions de france elle
aurait voulu avoir un rôle encore plus
fort il ya un équilibre qui a été dit a
été trouvé et naturellement elle sans
représenter après c'est évidemment au
président de région et à leurs
associations de désigner les personnes
pour les représenter à ce titre là à ce
titre là on critique également son rôle
de porte parole sur le fait qu' il
faudrait respecter le secret bancaire
donc à elle serait le porte-parole de
quoi bon vous savez là on est carrément
dans je dirais le où le procès
d'intention ou le commentaire québec et
pas d'un passé elle est président d'une
région elle a été candidate à l'élection
présidentielle c'est quelqu'un de
responsable et je ne vois pas pourquoi
elle en particulier on les ferait ce
reproche alors que dans ce conseil
d'administration il ya d'autres élus il
ya des responsables et à l'aide sera
responsable à ce poste là comme les à la
présidence de poitou-charentes très bien
m'écouter merci beaucoup alain vidalis
d'avoir répondu cet après midi à nos
questions en direct
je vais vous laisser rejoindre
tranquillement et voilà reprendre votre
place dans l'hémicycle du sénat pour
suivre cette séance nous mêmes nous
allons pouvoir lui cela suivre en direct
sur notre antenne
je vous rappelle les principaux thèmes
de ces questions d'actualité aujourd'hui
tout d'abord alors que le salon de
l'agriculture va s'ouvrir dans deux
jours un salon vous pourrez d'ailleurs
suivre en direct sur notre antenne à
partir de samedi matin
eh bien deux questions autour de la
sphère de la viande de cheval une
question tour de la filière viande et
puis une autre question autour de la
traçabilité de la viande une question
sur les dotations aux collectivités
locales alors qu'il ya eu des annonces
importantes de la part du premier
ministre
cette semaine et puis une question sur
le droit de vote des étrangers on vient
d'en parler avec alain vidalis le
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement
également une question sur le comité
interministériel des villes qui s'est
tenue lundi vous le voyez sur ces images
jean pierre bel le président du sénat se
dirige vers l'hémicycle le premier
ministre ne sera pas présent cet après
midi au sénat pour les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
mais parmi les ministres qui seront sur
les bancs du gouvernement
eh bien on peut citer marylise lebranchu
pour la réforme de l'état et la fonction
publique manuel valls le ministre de
l'intérieur cécile duflot ont la
ministre de l'égalité des territoires et
du logement ou encore benoît hamon
chargé de l'économie sociale et de la
consommation qui répondra notamment à
ces deux questions autour de la
traçabilité de la viande
voilà nous allons pouvoir rejoindre tout
de suite l'hémicycle du sénat poursuivre
sur ces questions d'actualité on se
retrouve après ici avec nos invités ce
matin ministre pour revenir sur ces
différents points tout à l'ordre du jour
appelle et des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
je rappelle que l'auteur de la question
de même que le ou la ministre pour sa
réponse disposent chacun de deux minutes
trente
je vous demanderais de bien vouloir vous
plier à cette règle qui est absolument
nécessaire au bon fonctionnement de nos
questions d'actualité la parole et pour
la première question à madame catherine
trop élevé pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre délégué chargé du budget
monsieur le ministre votre majorité a
été élu sur le mensonge pour prétendit
réconcilier les français entre eux vous
ne cessez de les monter les uns contre
les autres en proposant des lois de
société qui divise profondément les
français en opposant les salariés du
privé ceux du public avec la suppression
du jour de carence pour les ans tout
votre programme n'était que mensonges
vous avait abrogé la hausse de la tva
qui allait permettre de lutter contre
les délocalisations
trois mois plus tard vous l'avez
rétablis de manière plus lourde et moins
efficace vous avez prétendu que votre
hausse des impôts historique allait
permettre de ramener le déficit à 3 %
alors qu'elle n'a servi qu'à payer vos
cadeaux électoraux pour prétendiez
ériger une république impartiale
mais depuis françois mitterrand vous
n'avez jamais autant nous n'avons jamais
vu autant d'arbitraire et de copinage
en décembre vous aviez radié du corps
préfectoral les préfet nommé par le
gouvernement précédent
le mois suivant vous nommer préfet une
cohorte de collaborateurs du parti
socialiste
nous apprenons que battu aux élections
madame royal sera nommé vice président
de la banque publique d'investissement
plus grave encore en neuf mois vous avez
proposé de changer tous les modes de
scrutin de la république pour contourner
la sanction électorale au lieu de vous
atteler aux problèmes des français
votre dernier renoncement concerne les
collectivités et l'engagement 50 cas du
candidat hollande promettait de garantir
le niveau actuel des dotations nouveau
mensonge
en décembre vous avez adopté une baisse
de 2,25 milliards d'euros de dotation
pour les collectivités en février vous
proposez aussitôt de doubler ce rabot en
le portant 4 5 milliards dois je vous
rappeler vos cris indignés lorsque nous
avions envisagé une baisse de 0,2
milliard
même votre majorité se sont trahis
le président socialiste du cfl andré
laignel a affirmé que cela stoppe rats
les investissements des collectivités
alors qu'elles réalisent 70% des
investissements publics
le président socialiste de l'adf claudy
lebreton redoutent la perte de centaines
de milliers d'emplois principalement
dans le btp monsieur le ministre
allez-vous arrêter d'être anglais les
collectivités qui sont en support de
l'investissement dans notre pays a grand
besoin pour maintenir son économie
je vous remercie
merci la parole est à madame marylise
lebranchu ministre de la réforme de
l'état de la décentralisation de la
fonction publique merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice et une partie de la question à
laquelle je crois que je ne vais pas
répondre sur les nominés h sur les
nominations en particulier je crois que
avec le ministre de l'intérieur on
pourrait faire un certain nombre de
liste de nominations récentes et vous en
seriez je pense très satisfaite compte
tenu de l'équilibré de la loyauté qui a
été celle des gens nommés donc sur cet
aspect des choses je pense qu'il faut
faire attention à ce que nous disons les
uns et les autres est la république acr
ses règles et je pense qu'elles sont
respectées mais pour en revenir à la
situation des collectivités
territoriales la situation budgétaire
je vous rappelle que pendant la campagne
électorale en particulier madame valérie
pécresse qui me l'a confirmé
tout à fait honnêtement est clairement
lors de la passation de pouvoir avait
envisagé très sérieusement 2 milliards
de baisses des dotations tous les ans
avec le ministre du budget est sous
l'autorité du premier ministre nous
avions pensé que pour la première année
même si effectivement tout était
discutable
il fallait garder une stabilité de la
ressource tels que le président de la
république l'avait proposé pour essayer
d'équilibrer cette crise violente dont
nous n'avons en aucun cas vous
l'admettrez bien volontiers la
responsabilité nous avons donc choisi de
ne pas diminuer les dotations des
collectivités territoriales pour tenir
le tissu des pme et tpe ce que qu'est ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui nous avons
besoin de faire des économies
supplémentaires
nous n'allons pas chercher 10 milliards
d'euros madame mais deux fois 1 milliard
et demi auprès des collectivités et dans
le même temps nous prenons un engagement
fort et que j'espère vous allez entendre
avec satisfaction c'est de suivre
d'abord la première des commissions que
le premier ministre as salé pour les
départements de france parce que les
départements de france ont des
difficultés à servir les allocations
voter au niveau national et donc pour
les départements de france il faut
trouver une ressource pérenne et le
travail doit être terminés à l'été
ensuite pour l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales
si la péréquation horizontale a permis
des ajustements et encore avec des
débats difficiles
vous les avez vécu ici nous les avons
vécues à l'assemblée nationale nous nous
pensons qu'il faut revenir aussi à une
recherche de fiscalité horizontale
réécrire courageusement et tous ensemble
et le premier ministre va réunir à cet
effet l'ensemble des présidents des
collectivités territoriales pour
travailler à une réécriture de la
dotation globale de base qui soit plus
juste
nous voulons être plus justes madame il
va nous allons effectivement demandé 1 1
25% d'efforts aux collectivités
territoriales dont la part dans la
dépense publique vous le savez est de
20% à 25% sur 244 milliards d'euros
l'ensemble des élus locaux de france
sauront le faire si la parole est à
présent monsieur jean claude merceron
pour le groupe union des démocrates et
indépendants us et monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de l'artisanat du
commerce et du tourisme l'artisanat est
le premier employeur de france
acteur majeur de la formation
professionnelle et premier aménageur du
territoire puisque les emplois sont des
emplois de proximité qui plus est non
d'école et glauque à lisa blue en vendée
l'artisanat du bâtiment est une
plus-value des communes rurales qui
participent à leur cohésion sociale
acteurs visibles à la fois du
développement économique et de la vie
associative
néanmoins comme dans toutes les régions
il est touché de plein fouet par les
conséquences des crises financières et
sociales
- 20 % de mises en chantier de logements
neufs selon le ministère du logement
le bâtiment est donc va donc faire face
de manière encore plus douloureuse
aujourd'hui aux contraintes
administratives à la concurrence
déloyale engendrés par l'avenue
d'artisans d'autres pays à une fiscalité
décourageante et à des charges sociales
pénalisante
j'ai bien pris acte du pacte pour
l'artisanat que vous avez présenté au
lendemain de la journée de mobilisation
des professionnels du bâtiment
le 18 janvier dernier mais ce n'est pas
là-dessus que je vous interrogerez
l'objet de ma question est la suivante
pour 2014
le gouvernement prévoit une nouvelle
augmentation de la tva qui passerait de
7 à 10%
trop c'est trop le rythme de la
construction va encore diminuer et
l'objectif des 500 milles logements
rénovés par an sera alors hors de portée
ainsi dans la perspective de la
prochaine loi de finances
et pour soutenir la rénovation des
logements notamment pour améliorer leur
isolation thermique et réduire leur
collation leur consommation d'énergie
je vous demande pour nos emplois pour
notre économie pour les centres de nos
villes et de nos bourgs le retour à une
tva réduite incitatives pour ces travaux
je vous en remercie merci madame sylvia
pinel ministre de l'artisanat du
commerce et du tourisme
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vous avez raison de souligner
l'importance du secteur de l'artisanat
et notamment de l'artisanat du bâtiment
dans notre pays
effectivement trois millions d'actifs
plus d'un million d'entreprises 10% du
pib
le gouvernement travaille en lien avec
les organisations professionnelles pour
les accompagner vous m'interrogez plus
particulièrement sur la question de la
hausse de la tva mais vous avez monsieur
le sénateur et vous le savez dans le
cadre du pacte de compétitivité que le
gouvernement a présenté les entreprises
de l'artisanat et notamment de
l'artisanat du bâtiment bénéficieront du
crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi à
hauteur de 2 milliards d'euros alors que
la hausse de la tva est évaluée à 1,8
milliard d'euros
ce secteur aura donc 200 millions
d'euros de bénéfices et vous avez vous
savez aussi que les contrats de
génération que le gouvernement met en
oeuvre bénéficieront très largement à ce
secteur créateur d'emplois avec un volet
spécifique sur la transmission reprise
de ces entreprises qui ont des
difficultés pour trouver des repreneurs
et c'est un tout l'ensemble de ces
mesures et lorsque j'ai présenté le
pacte pour l'artisanat
vous avez vu que nous prêtions une
attention particulière à ce secteur de
l'artisanat du bâtiment puisque un
groupe de travail interministériel se
réunira
j'animerai en lien avec mes autres
collègues toutes ces questions tous ces
sujets de préoccupation parce que la tva
n'est pas le seul sujet qui inquiète ses
entreprises
la fiscalité les besoins de trésorerie
la construction de logements le plan de
rénovation thermique la concurrence
déloyale par rapport au travail illégal
tout ces sujets seront mis sur la table
et avec mes autres collègues nous
apporterons des réponses sur la
fiscalité mais aussi surtout ceux qui
créent de l'emploi qui crée de
l'activité dans ce secteur
vous le voyez monsieur le sénateur la
politique du gouvernement en la matière
et cohérente pacte de compétitivité
pacte pour l'artisanat
notre objectif est bien celui
d'accompagner ces entreprises de leur
permettre de se développer de créer de
l'emploi en france parce qu'un si elles
concourront comme les autres au
redressement économique de notre pays
merci la parole est à monsieur georges
admiration pour le groupe socialiste
apparentés
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur les
ministres d'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire de la forêt et elle
concerne le dossier de la fraude la
viande qui a juste dit inquiète nos
compatriotes dans un contexte il faut
bien le dire d'un forte emballement
médiatique
je tiens d'abord à souligner et a salué
le fait que le gouvernement et tout
particulièrement les ministres concernés
je veux parler des messieurs le foll à
mon égard aux ondes agi dans le cadre de
leurs prérogatives respectives avec
rapidité et fermeté discernement et
transparence c'était dur est
indispensable pour démontrer aux
consommateurs que sans confiance des
pouvoirs publics français et père aimant
justifiée mais il faut aussi parler le
mans constater que les méandres européen
qu'empruntent les viandes transformées
sont extrêmement complexes et ce dossier
démontre parce qu'il ya eu manifestement
rupture de la traçabilité que les
dispositifs de contrôle sont à améliorer
car au bout du compte et au niveau du
dernier maillon de la chaîne
il est absolument indispensable que le
consommateur sache ce qu'il a dans son
assiette
sur un plan plus local les s'agissant
des salariés de la société spanghero de
la population de castelnaudary des élus
locaux concernés et des parlementaires
de l'aude
il était également impératif de les
rassurer en ce qui concerne leurs
inquiétudes notamment relatifs à la
pérennité à la pérennité des emplois des
sociétés concernées
de ce point de vue la suspension de
l'agrément qui n'a pas dépassé 4 jours
était pleinement justifiée et
s'inscrivait dans cette logique les
enquêtes sanitaires administratives et
vétérinaire permettront quant à elle de
savoir ce qui s'est passé d'en tirer les
conséquences et de prendre les sanctions
à l'égard des auteurs de cette fraude
plus généralement dans cette affaire qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre d'un commerce
alimentaire engageant une recherche
frénétique du profit ou des produits de
base de l'alimentation humaine sont
désignés par le test par le terme
tristement révélateur de minerai et
c'est ainsi qu'un six mois on évoque une
vente de 750 tonnes de viande de cheval
à la place de viande de boeuf qui aurait
dégagé 1 / profit de 550000 euros
beaucoup reste donc à faire pour arriver
à une solution satisfaisante qui puisse
garantir à la fois les intérêts des
salariés
de la filière concernée mais également
et surtout ceux des consommateurs
ma question monsieur le ministre la
suivante pouvez vous nous faire un point
d'actualité sur un dossier compliqué qui
évolue très vite et quelles sont les
pistes de travail pouvait entendre des
privilégiés pour qui une telle affaire
ne se reproduise pas merci monsieur
stéphane le foll ministres agriculture
agroalimentaire et d'un fort et je le
président monsieur le sénateur monsieur
mirassou jouets répondre à votre
question avec plusieurs éléments à la
fois sur la question vous avez au quai
de la confiance ce qui s'est passé est
une fraude généralisée
en tout cas pour les produits qui ont
été concernés qui a des enquêtes à
l'échelle européenne
nous avons saisi d'ailleurs europol
parce que nous pensions que tout ça
n'est pas simplement un circuit entre ce
que vous savez la roumanie les pays bas
et la france
il faut à partir de là à voir vous
l'avez souligné rapidité dans la réponse
et puis clarté dans les objectifs que
l'on poursuit la rapidité a été de faire
une enquête de diligenter cette enquête
trouver des éléments qui permettent
actuellement de considérer qu'il ya eu
une fraude et de transmettre à la
justice
c'était aussi pour l'entreprise
spanghero et je fais bien la différence
entre le nom de l'entreprise et la
famille spanghero le fait de mettre en
oeuvre une enquête sanitaire et pour que
cette enquête sanitaire se fasse dans de
bonnes conditions
il a fallu suspendre l'agrément cette
enquête sera rendue définitive demain
puisqu'il y avait encore un certain
nombre de d'enquêteurs sur place
elle a permis une reprise de l'activité
pour les activités concernées qui
n'avait rien à voir avec la partie du
négoce qui est celui qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui
à partir de là ce matin une réunion a eu
lieu au ministère de l'agriculture
réunissant les ministres à la fois
guillaume garot et benoît hamon pour
faire le point avec l'ensemble de la
filière
parce que de ce qui s'est passé il faut
qu'on en tire des conclusions il ya un
retour sur cette triste affaire qu'il va
falloir faire
3e trois objectifs sont fixés et ils ont
été actés par l'ensemble des acteurs qui
dans ce sujet entre transformateurs
entre producteurs entre distributeurs et
industriels agroalimentaires n'est
jamais facile
trois objectifs à la fois à l'échelle
européenne pour suivre pour changer la
réglementation et assurer plus de
traçabilité et d'étiquetage en
particulier sur les origines des viandes
deuxième objectif faire que la france
anticipe ses évolutions et soit
exemplaire sur la manière dont elle
organisera elle même la traçabilité des
produits transformés avec en particulier
les références à la viande bovine
française et dernier point aussi
important le fait qu'un groupe de
travail va être mis en place pour faire
en sorte que sur cette question des
fraudes
on renforce l'ensemble du dispositif qui
permet aux acteurs eux mêmes
hanotaux contrôle et surtout des saisies
plus rapide de la dgccrf
voilà les conclusions à la fois qu'ils
sont en cours et voilà ce que nous avons
fait merci merci
la parole est à madame esther benbassa
pour le groupe écologiste si on
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur en décembre 2011 nous
débattions ici même d'une proposition de
loi visant à accorder aux étrangers non
communautaires le droit de vote et
d'éligibilité aux élections locales
je n'étais la rapporteure sénatrice
novice est d'autant plus ému le sénat
lui venait de changer de majorité
et cette paix nous l'avons alors voter
dans un rare moment de communion
républicaine après la longue décennie
d'attentes qui nous séparait de son
adoption par l'assemblée nationale en
mai 2000 françois hollande élu président
nous avons espéré que sans tarder
justice serait enfin rendu à ces hommes
et à ces femmes qui vivent dans les
mêmes quartiers que nous envoient leurs
enfants dans les mêmes écoles et leurs
impôts et contribue depuis des décennies
à l'économie nationale
ils ont gardé nos enfants nettoyer nos
domiciles et nos bureaux
ayé dans nos usines construit nos
maisons nos routes et nos ponts et j'en
passe ils n'ont pas fait moins pour la
france que les étrangers communaux tels
qu'ils jouissent de ce droit de vote et
de jilib d'éligibilité du simple fait
d'être européen
disons le clairement si nos concitoyens
communautaire partage bien notre projet
européen commun les étrangers non
communautaires issus dans leur majorité
de nos anciennes colonies ne sont pas
moins partie prenante d'une histoire qui
nous est commune à 1 comment nous
monsieur le ministre nous savons que la
tâche est complexe
n'oublions pas pourtant que plus dun
ténors de l'ancienne majorité s'était
prononcé dans le passé pour ce vote
cette bataille n'est pas une bataille
entre la gauche et la droite sont
l'enjeu est autre le supérieur une
certaine conception de la démocratie une
même aspiration peut tous nous réunir
celles de faire de notre pays un exemple
d'ouverture aux étrangers qui respectent
la légalité républicaine et qui ont le
souci aussi bien de simples opus mérité
que de sa sécurité
monsieur le monsieur le ministre les
promesses de monsieur hollande nous
engage
nous ne pouvons pas reculer sur celles
ci n'ont plus que sur les autres
nous n'avons pas le droit de décevoir si
nous ne parvenons pas à convaincre trois
cinquièmes des parlementaires de nous
rejoindre
pourquoi alors ne pas envisager
sérieusement avec courage et avec toute
la force de notre conviction dont nous
sommes capables
la possibilité de référendum voici la
boue voici la question que se posent
nombre de nos concitoyens mille étangs
associative en tête et quand mon tour je
vous pose aujourd'hui eva les ventes
l'avait vote avait demandé en 2005
calmez-vous un peu oui merci
merci ma parole à monsieur manuel valls
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice esther
benbassa la majorité souhaite l'adoption
du droit de vote aux élections locales
pour les étrangers résidant de manière
régulière sur notre territoire qui sont
extra communautaires vous l'avez voter
d'ailleurs vouloir avait rappelé ici au
sénat c'est un engagement du président
de la république vous l'avez dit aussi
plusieurs reprises le gouvernement s'est
exprimée à montrer sa volonté de faire
aboutir cette réforme est d'ailleurs les
esprits peuvent évoluer
quant au moment du traité de maastricht
il a été inscrit que les membres de
l'union européenne pouvaient voter aux
élections locales ou européennes ont
changé d'une certaine manière la nature
du rapport entre les citoyens et la
nation où j'ai moi même d'ailleurs était
le rapporteur des différentes
propositions de loi du groupe socialiste
dans l'opposition au de ces dernières
années sur ce sujet là j'ai moi même vu
mes parents espagnols pour la première
fois votée en 2001 mais au delà des
convictions
au delà des proclamations l'essentiel
est d'aboutir et vous le savez la
réussite de ce projet est conditionnée
ne faisons pas comme si cela n'existait
pas toute réforme constitutionnelle pas
ce sens devant le congrès nécessite de
réunir trois cinquièmes des suffrages
exprimés et les voix de la majorité
additionnée au sénat et à l'assemblée
nationale ne suffisent pas il faut donc
écouter convaincre le premier ministre a
consulté tous les groupes parlementaires
de la majorité et de l'opposition sur
les sujets nécessitant une réforme
constitutionnelle
il a interrogé les gros sur ce sujet là
le premier vise le gouvernement
recherche les conditions nécessaires
pour atteindre la majorité des trois
cinquièmes sur ce sujet là mais aussi
sur les autres ce sujet l'objet d'un
clivage fort
vous le savez vous l'avez dit
avec l'opposition avec la droite qui
refuse cette avancée la résistance vient
de cette partie là pas du gouvernement
pas de la majorité même si il y à
quelques années vous l'avez souligné
monsieur nicolas sarkozy monsieur jean
louis borloo monsieur yves jégo avait
fait pas monsieur raffarin donc avait
fait part nous dit-on de dollars de
l'heure de leur souhait mais chacun ça
peut arriver à changer d'avis le premier
ministre va prochainement rendre compte
de ses consultations ce peut m'arriver
aussi le premier ministre va
prochainement ronde de ces consultations
attendons ses conclusions sur le
référendum
nous sommes ici au sénat vous le savez
c'est de la prérogative exclusive du
président de la république est le seul
élément que je pourrais rajouter en
ayant planté ainsi le décor c'est de
souligner la chose suivante
sur ce sujet comme sur d'autres le
président de la république comme le
gouvernement souhaite rassemblé apaisé
sur tous les sujets et faisant attention
uniquement
faisons attention les uns et les autres
sur ces questions là surtout si elles ne
peuvent pas aboutir à ne pas diviser
davantage mais vous aurez madame la
sénatrice une réponse du gouvernement
ce qui n'exclut pas les initiatives
parlementaires vous aurez une réponse du
gouvernement sur ce sujet merci d'après
l'état monsieur thierry foucaud on le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur cahuzac
un ministre chargé du budget mes chers
collègues la situation économique de
notre pays comme de l'europe vous le
savez est très préoccupante alors que l'
ocde annonce que les pays membres de
l'organisation présente eu une
croissance de 1,5 pour cent en 2012
la zone euro connaît
elle une récession globale de -0 6%
je dois dire fruits amers des politiques
d'austérité imposées aux peuples bien
sûr pour atteindre les objectifs de
convergence des politiques économiques
et notamment la règle des 3% de déficit
budgétaire à respecter coûte que coûte
et quoi qu'il en coûte
en 2012 la croissance est à washington
elle est aussi à pékin
elle n'est ni albert là ni à paris et je
dois dire encore moins à athènes après
le vote d'ailleurs d'une loi de finances
2013 marqué par la réduction des
déficits publics
la hausse des impôts et notamment le gel
de la dépense publique mais celui aussi
malheureusement d'un collectif
budgétaire
gajan d'ailleurs le crédit d'impôt aux
entreprises je rappelle 20 milliards sur
la hausse
d'ailleurs de la tva voici en ce moment
que quelques esprits
je dirais bien intentionnés viennent de
lancer le concours d idées pour réduire
les déficits
l'un demande à la france d'aller plus
loin dans la flexibilité du marché du
travail comme si la solution était mes
chers collègues dans le développement de
la précarité
l'autre recommande de s'attaquer aux
allocations familiales
d'autres recommandent de geler la
progression des retraites
quitte d'ailleurs à poser aux retraités
une hausse de la csg c'est un patron
américain d'ailleurs qui se permet
d'insulter les travailleurs français est
d'ores et déjà on annonce le doublement
de la baisse des dotations aux
collectivités locales en 2014 et en 2015
fixé en loi de programmation si l'on
veut réduire les déficits il faut de la
croissance mes chers collègues parce que
seule la croissance dégagera les
recettes fiscales et sociales
nécessaires
même le fmi là vous mets une politique
de croissance va de pair je dois dire
avec un appareil industriel
enfin soutenu par une politique publique
audacieuse et cohérente
un système bancaire enfin millions de
morts de financer l'activité économique
plus
que la spéculation une rupture également
avec les politiques européennes qui vous
le savez ont conduit la grèce et
l'espagne au dessus des 25 % de chômeurs
la france et l'allemagne à la récession
au dernier trimestre 2012
alors avec l'austérité telle que
pratiquée aujourd'hui c'est celle de
l'europe qui s'abaisse c'est l'europe
qui décline
quand le reste du monde lui connaît la
croissance la france doit apporter
monsieur le ministre
une autre parole lors du prochain
conseil européen des 14 et 15 mars
prochain et nous devons consommer
quasiment terminée en france
je pose la question monsieur le
président un collectif budgétaire
rompant avec la stricte logique du
traité de lisbonne face à cette
situation monsieur le ministre que va
faire le gouvernement pour sortir la
france de l'ornière des politiques
libérales de la zone euro merci la
parole est à monsieur jérôme cahuzac
ministre chargé du budget merci monsieur
le président monsieur le sénateur j'ai
bien entendu l'hommage que vous avez
rendu et au fmi et aux dirigeants nord
américains puisque vous avez cité
washington ainsi qu'aux dirigeants
chinois puisque vous avez cité pékin je
n'ai pas de jugement à porter sur les
politiques sociales menées dans ces pays
encore que selon moi je crois qu'il
serait préjudiciable aux salariés
français de leur voir appliquer les
conditions de travail que par exemple on
peut constater en république populaire
de chine mais au-delà de ces
appréciations que l'on peut porter sur
les politiques menées par des pays avec
lesquels nous avons des liens d'amitié
indéfectibles je veux simplement vous
indiquer que le gouvernement a décidé
d'une politique les dernières et que
cette politique le gouvernement a décidé
de la poursuivre car cette politique est
nécessaire elle n'est pas nécessaire
parce qu'elle nous serait imposé elle
est nécessaire parce que nous l'avons
décidé et que c'est celle dont le pays a
besoin
aucune institution aucun pays ami
quelle que soit la proximité que nous
pouvons avoir avec lui aucun de ceux-là
ne peut imposer à la france une
politique que notre pays n'aurait à
consentir si ils n'en décide autrement
cette politique le gouvernement l'a donc
décider librement il s'agit d'une
politique permettez moi cette expression
de restauration de la souveraineté
nationale
nous ne pouvons plus en france dépendre
comme nous avons pu le constater ces
dernières années et des marchés et des
agences de notation tant il est vrai que
passé un certain temps dans l'année
c'est par l'emprunt que notre pays est
obligé de financer ses politiques
publiques c'est précisément cette
dépendance à l'emprunt c'est à dire
cette aliénation de notre souveraineté
nationale a démarché des agences de
notation avec laquelle le gouvernement
de jean marc ayrault a décidé de rompre
et cette politique est en train de
porter ses fruits car en 2012 comme en
2013 nous allons procéder à un
ajustement structurel de nos finances
publiques par un déficit structurel a
baissé de près de 3,1 pour cent de pipe
il faut nous désendetter tant il est
vrai qu'au bout d'un moment rajoutez de
l'emprunt à l'emprunt n'a jamais pu
créer de la croissance
je me permet d'ailleurs de rappeler que
ces cinq dernières années le déficit
structurel de notre pays s'est aggravée
de près de 1.2 pipe quand il vient de
baisser grâce au vote du parlement de
3,1 pour cent de pib grâce aux lois de
finances initiale et rectificative
s'applique en 2012 et en 2013
cette politique nous allons donc la
poursuivre je voudrais d'ailleurs
remarquer qu' il est particulièrement
difficile nous le savons tous de
procéder à un ajustement budgétaire
quand la conjoncture économique ne s'y
prête pas mais pour autant nous devons
le faire sans que en 2013 des politiques
de réduction des dépenses ou des hausses
de la fiscalité supplémentaire ne soit
décidée car il exclut de rajouter de
l'austérité à je ne sais quelle rigueur
ou de l'impossibilité à des difficultés
déjà tout à fait grande en revanche en
2014 et à l'occasion de la loi de
finances initiale nous aurons j'en suis
sûr l'occasion de sueur sénateur de
débattre de la politique économique du
pays
merci la parole est à monsieur gilbert
barbier pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen sur le
président mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur me lisent
l'agriculture de l'agroalimentaire et de
la forêt est évoquée à quelques instants
l'europe entière s'indigne à juste titre
d'une fraude organisée qui a permis de
faire consommer effectivement 750 tonnes
de viande de cheval
estampillée pur boeuf au delà des
conséquences sur les ventes sur les
plats cuisinés 7 à terre
à jeter un doute sur l'ensemble de la
filière agroalimentaire française
c'est en tout cas ce qu'indiquent les
derniers sondages pour beaucoup de
consommateurs
ce scandale n'est pas un accident isolé
les interroge sur la composition et la
provenance réelle des produits
alimentaires malgré les étiquetages la
plupart des produits laitiers des
fromages industriels seraient par
exemple fabriquée avec du lait
d'importation d'origine inconnue ceci
est il révélateur d'une détérioration de
la qualité des produits alimentaires
français
je ne le pense pas les producteurs
français s'attachent à produire des
produits de qualité avec des critères
définis
daou ces dix gp le label rouge et
caetera et des contraintes de production
il est dommage qu'un fraudeur jette la
suspicion sur l'ensemble de la filière
ma question ne concerne pas la gestion
de cette affaire par le gouvernement
mais les suites qu'il entend y donner
en premier lieu les exigences fortes en
matière de sécurité sanitaire nécessite
de conserver des moyens de contrôles
adaptés aussi bien par les services
vétérinaires que par l' agence nationale
de sécurité sanitaire de l'alimentation
ou de la dgccrf la responsabilité
d'entreprise ou l'autocontrôle sans
doute une bonne chose mais elle a des
limites
on le voit bien c'est bien à ces
organismes publics d'exercer une
surveillance efficace sans attendre que
lé scandale arrive en second lieu c'est
à cette malheureuse affaire en plus
évidente la nécessité de renforcer
l'information des consommateurs
ils ont droit à la transparence totale
sur les produits qu'ils achètent en
europe et au niveau européen monsieur le
ministre vous venez de nous dire qu'on
réfléchisse à un étiquetage pour les
plats préparés
mais face à la lenteur de bruxelles
envisagez vous monsieur le ministre de
prendre les devants à la veille du salon
de l'agriculture
il est important que le monde agricole
attendent la reconnaissance de la
qualité de ses produits et peut-être
aussi des mesures favorisant le
développement des circuits courts
gage de transparence pour le
consommateur
sur tous ces sujets nous attendons des
engagements et des résultats merci pour
vous répondre c'est monsieur benoît
hamon ministre chargé de l'économie
sociale et solidaire et de la
consommation qui a la parole
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur barbier dans cette affaire sur
laquelle je vais revenir une minute
quatre millions cinq cent mille
personnes ont acheté du boeuf et manger
du cheval ou acheter du cheval au prix
du boeuf permettant à un intermédiaire
ou plusieurs de réaliser un joli
bénéfice au passage
et pour ceux qui ne concerne que la
responsabilité des entreprises
françaises nous avons estimé que sur la
période de six mois l'équivalent de 550
mille euros de bénéfices indus avait été
réalisée en vendant ainsi du cheval au
prix du boeuf aux consommateurs français
et européens ce sont 13 pays qui ont été
avertis par nos soins la dgccrf dont
vous avez parlé 28 entreprises et qui
nous ont permis depuis maintenant une
semaine de contrôler à travers trois
mille interventions la réalité des
retraits et des rappels des produits
concernés
nous avons voulu dès le départ mesuré ce
qu'était la nature du préjudice est là
aujourd'hui l' enquête judiciaire se
concentre sur la responsabilité de
l'établissement spanghero je ne me
rappelle pas la réalité d'étiquettes qui
ont été changés dans cet établissement
mais l enquête continue sur l'étendue du
préjudice
y at il d'autres filières
d'approvisionnement de transformation et
de commercialisation de boeuf qui
pourrait laisser à penser que l'on
continue à manger dans nos plats
préparés de la viande de cheval à la
place de la viande de boeuf
il est utile de dire que cette viande
n'est pas impropre à la consommation
mêlant demeure pas moins que c'est une
tromperie économique qui appelle
réparation au profit du consommateur
alors ce que nous avons voulu faire avec
les deux ministres le ministre de
l'agriculture et le ministre de l'agro
alimentaire c'est d'abord de rappeler
l'excellence de la filière bovine
française et l'excellence de la filière
agroalimentaire française
la nécessité d'agir vite au niveau
européen mais en respectant les rythmes
de ce que sont la négociation européenne
notamment sur la modification du
règlement aco et en faisant en sorte que
les professionnels français anticipent
l'évolution des règles européennes sur
un point le fait que figure l'origine
des produits notamment l'origine de la
viande dans l'étiquette des plats
préparés ses engagements en tout cas ces
avancées nous avons pu constater la
bonne volonté de l'ensemble des
professionnels cet après midi au
ministère de l'agriculture
c'est un point positif je vais vous dire
aussi qu'il faut tirer d'autres leçons
pour que notre système de protection
s'adapte aujourd'hui à la tromperie
économique
là où il est d'ores et déjà efficace
contre la menace sanitaire
si vous voulez une barquette surgelés
dans un magasin vous encourez trois ans
de prison et 45000 euros damende quand
vous trompez 4 millions et demi de
personnes pendant six mois vous encourez
37000 euros d'amendé et deux ans
d'emprisonnement
il faudra sans doute regarder le
caractère dissuasif de ces peines et le
projet de loi consommation y répondre à
un mot pour dire que vous avez signalé
l'importance du rôle de la dgccrf ses
agents au rab ont agi avec beaucoup de
célérité et d'efficacité
je note quand même que dans les cinq
dernières années ces agents ont vu leurs
effectifs baisser de 16%
raison pour laquelle le ministre jérôme
cahuzac et moi même avons voulu grâce au
premier ministre sanctuariser ses
effectifs pour cette année et qu'il
faudra conserver les moyens à la
puissance publique d'exercer ses tâches
de contrôler plus efficacement encore
dans les années à venir
c'est un engagement que nous prenons
aussi merci mademoiselle sophie
joissains pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame dominique
bertinotti ministre chargée de la
famille
rééquilibrer les comptes publics n'est
certes pas chose facile et en la matière
les valeurs de l'état s'exprime aussi
par la priorité qu'il donne aux mesures
qu'il met en place
certains domaines comme les avantages
des retraités ou les actions concernant
la politique familiale surtout dans le
temps de crise que nous traversons ne
pourront manquer d'être interprétée sur
un plan symbolique et idéologiques les
gouvernements précédents y ont été
confrontés et encore une fois la crise
ne pourra qu'accentuer
qu'amplifier le sens de toute mesure
prise sur ces secteurs l'image du couple
riche dénué de préoccupations
matérielles touchant des allocations
confronté à celui peinant pour nourrir
ses enfants pourraient influer dans le
sens des mesures sur les allocations
familiales préconisé par le président de
la cour des comptes
mais cette image est une image d'epinal
seule la classe moyenne celle que nous
devons conforter mobiliser revitaliser
subira réellement cette diminution des
allocations familiales
les allocations familiales ne sont pas
un outil de répartition et de justice
sociale
il s'agit à ça j'ai à salaire égal de
favoriser les couples qui décident de
faire des enfants
la jeunesse d'un état est une condition
ou à paramètre essentiel à tout
développement
et en ce sens ces allocations familiales
constituent un investissement sûr
l'avenir
de plus l'état en maintenant le principe
d'universalité préserve un lien
politique incitatif et protecteur avec
l'ensemble des familles françaises
toucher aux allocations familiales c'est
prendre le risque de modifier le contrat
social dans le partage par tous les
français est crucial dans la période que
nous traversons accroître le clivage
entre les français paraît aujourd'hui
bien dangereux et bien risqué ceci
d'autant plus que nous pourrions en
amont de ce type de mesures revisiter
certains postes de la dépense publique
pouvez vous madame le ministre nous
indiquer si le gouvernement maintient
cette piste de rééquilibrage budgétaire
et si tel est le cas quelle est la forme
de diminution des allocations familiales
qu'ils privilégient l'intégration de
leurs montants à l'impôt c'est à dire
oui la hausse des prélèvements
ou bien leurs attributions sous
conditions de ressources ce qui battrait
évidemment en brèche le principe
d'universalité de la politique familiale
merci madame dominique bertinotti
ministre chargée de la famille
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice je voudrais quand même
rappeler un certain nombre de réalités
qui témoigne de la pertinence du
questionnement du gouvernement sur cette
question comment on pourrait aujourd'hui
refuser de se questionner à l'heure
que c'est sous le précédent gouvernement
que la branche famille
eh oui que la branche famille qui
n'était pas déficitaire les deux venus
au fur et à mesure des années qui se
sont écoulées sous le quinquennat
précédent passant d'un déficit de 300
millions d'euros en 2008 un déficit de
2,6 milliards en 2011
comment expliquer comment ne pas se
questionner lorsque c'est vous qui avez
sous indexer des prestations familiales
provoquant une perte de pouvoir d'achat
de l'ensemble de ces familles de l'ordre
de 600 millions d'euros
comment s'interdirait ton de se
questionner alors qu'avec 3,7 pour cent
du produit intérieur brut qui est
affectée aux allocations familiales et
aux allégements d'impôts la france est
certes en tête des pays européens en ce
qui concerne les dépenses en faveur de
la famille mais bien loin d'être en tête
en ce qui concerne la lutte contre la
pauvreté des enfants comme l'a rappelé
très cruellement rapport récent de
l'unicef
comment refuser de se questionner alors
que les attentes et les besoins des
familles ont évolué et une là aussi une
analyse du credoc leur rappelle 69 % des
parents considèrent aujourd'hui
préférable pour mieux aider les familles
de leur fournir des aides sous forme
d'équipements et de services contre 30%
qui optent pour des prestations
financières
comment refuser de se questionner alors
que les sondages récents montrent que
les français eux mêmes sont prêts à
envisager des évolutions dans notre
système
alors effectivement vous voyez la
pertinence que le premier ministre a eu
de saisir
bertrand fragonard président du haut
conseil à la famille d'une mission
globale sur les aides aux familles il
lui a été demandé à partir des aides
existantes d'établir une cartographie et
et cet exercice devra déboucher sur des
propositions cohérentes d'évolution car
il est légitime de se questionner sur
l'économie générale du système d' aide
aux familles
architecture d'ensemble efficience des
dispositifs pertinence de leur ciblage
il est légitime de rechercher une
combinaison mieux adapté aux besoins
actuels entre les aides financières plus
redistributive et le développement des
services comme les modes d'accueil des
enfants et de soutien aux parents alors
vous vous pensez que l'immuabilité est
un gage d'avenir
eh bien nous nous pensons que la justice
et l'équité l'égalité est le véritable
gage d'avenir
merci la parole est à monsieur daniel
raoul pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés 6 merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres ma
question s'adresse au ministre délégué
chargé de la ville depuis la loi
d'orientation de programmation pour la
ville et la rénovation urbaine de 2003
les politiques menées par les
gouvernements successifs
nota t'as aucun des objectifs qu'il
s'était fixés il est vrai que la baisse
constante des crédits alloués aux
politiques de la ville depuis 2008 - 50
% ne sont sans doute pas étrangères à
cet échec selon l'observatoire national
des zones urbaines sensibles les écarts
de développement ne se sent pas réduit
bien au contraire
aujourd'hui encore plus d'un résident
habitants dans un quartier populaire et
pauvres contre un sur huit dans le reste
du territoire
le taux de chômage y est deux fois et
demie plus élevé qu'ailleurs
une famille sur quatre est monoparentale
contre une sur dix dans les aires
urbaines environnantes et on pourrait
continuer la liste des indicateurs la
cour des comptes dans son rapport sévère
de juillet 2012 sur la politique de la
ville analysait cette absence de progrès
comme le résultat d'une dilution des
interventions sur un non de trop grand
de quartier des défauts persistants de
gouvernance et de coordination un manque
d'articulation entre rénovation urbaine
et accompagnement social une répartition
inadéquate des crédits dédiés à la
politique de la ville
enfin une trop faible mobilisation des
politiques
public de droit commun monsieur le
ministre vous avez lancé à l'automne
large concertation à laquelle notre
collègue claude il a été étroitement
associés et en particulier pour présider
un groupe de travail en vue de réformer
la politique de la ville rassemblant
environ 150 membres représentant
l'ensemble des acteurs locaux et
nationaux concernés cette concertation
qui est une démarche novatrice a abouti
à la formulation de propositions
nombreuses et opérationnelles elles ont
été soumises au gouvernement est
présenté sans doute lors du comité
interministériel de la ville qui s'est
tenue mardi dernier
toutes ces propositions doivent tendre
vers le même objectif mettre un terme
aux stigmatisations territoriale des
quartiers et aux discriminations dont
sont victimes des habitants des
quartiers populaires
il s'agit d'un changement de philosophie
en faveur du rétablissement de l'égalité
républicaine dans les quartiers pouvez
vous nous en dire davantage monsieur le
ministre sur les propositions retenues
temps il y a urgence pour ces 8 millions
d'habitants des quartiers populaires
merci encore l'état monsieur françois
labit ministre chargé de la ville merci
je suis monsieur le président monsieur
le président raoul
je vous remercie de m'avoir interrogé
d'avoir interrogé dans son antre du
gouvernement sur sur la situation des
quartiers populaires qui je crois
concerne tous les sénateurs et toutes
les sénatrices quelles que soient les
bons sur lequel il se trouve c'est vrai
vous l'avez rappelé que la situation
dans ces deux quartiers
dans cette période de crise économique
et sociale est encore plus dur
vous avez cité les chiffres du chômage
c'est le plus frappant le taux de
chômage est en général deux fois
supérieur à celui de l'ensemble du
territoire et des fois pour les jeunes
de 16 à 25 ans trois fois supérieur à
celui du taux national
et puis ces quartiers vous l'avez dit
également ont été un trop souvent
montrés du doigt trop souvent à
stigmatiser à l'intérieur des des
discours publics alors le premier
ministre a décidé d'engager un
l'ensemble du gouvernement
il a effectivement retenu 27 décision
lors du conseil interministériel
des villes qui s'est tenue mardi 19
février c'est l'ensemble du gouvernement
qui est en train de s'engager en faveur
des quartiers populaires de quelle façon
je vais conventionnés avec l'ensemble
des ministres concernés de l'intérieur
de la sécurité du logement de l'emploi
de l'éducation de la famille des
outre-mer pour ne citer qu'eux du droit
des femmes
bien entendu pour regarder quels sont
les objectifs les moyens les méthodes
pour que l'ensemble des membres du
gouvernement agisse à l'intérieur du ces
quartiers populaires c'est la levée du
droit commun c'est surtout la
reconnaissance qu'il existe des
fractures territoriales et les idées
fracture urbaine à l'intérieur des
villes entre les villes entre les villes
et les territoires et qu'il est
nécessaire d'accès d'orienter des
politiques publiques vers ces quartiers
les plus en difficulté ces conventions
elles serviront ensuite concrètement à
alimenter des futurs contrats de ville
vous trouverez à la fois des opérations
de rénovation urbaine celle du plan
national de rénovation 1
mais bien entendu de nouvelle génération
d'opérations de rénovation urbaine qui
pourront être engagées dès la signature
des contrats de ville c'est à dire dès
vous trouverez à l'intérieur de ces
contrats de ville les opérations et les
actions de cohésion urbaine la levée du
droit commun et les crédits de la
politique de la ville dans les quartiers
à les plus prioritaires
ce sera se fera dans le cadre d'une
géographie prioritaire qui sera rénovée
sur la base de critères qui sont les
plus objectif possible est celui qui est
actuellement retenu c'est celui du
pourcentage de foyers en dessous du
revenu médian national et éventuellement
locale
ceci permettra et je pense que ça vous
intéressera tous de faire émerger les
poses de provôté qui existe dans des
villes moyennes en région et pour avoir
procédé à quelques simulations ces
derniers jours je peux vous dire par
exemple qu'une ville comme dirait une
ville comme auch ressortiront de la
géographie prioritaire jusqu'à l' sont
particulièrement concernés dont vous le
voyez c'est un plan d'ensemble c'est un
plan concret
ce n'est pas le énième plan d'urgence
aussi vite annoncée ou si c'est un plan
structurel que le gouvernement a décidé
d'engager merci monsieur le ministre la
parole et à madame michèle andré pour le
groupe socialiste et apparentés monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à madame à yamina benguigui
ministre en charge de la francophonie
madame la ministre vous êtes venu le 8
février dernier à l'assemblée nationale
vous exprimer devant le bureau
international de l'assemblée
parlementaire de la francophonie apf
réunis à paris lors de ce bureau nous
nous sommes penchés en particulier sur
la situation politique difficile de la
guinée de madagascar du mali de la
république arabe syrienne de la
république démocratique du congo et de
la tunisie
vous nous avez fait part de vos
engagements dynamique afin de mettre la
francophonie au coeur des préoccupations
à vos côtés nous défendons nombreux ces
valeurs démocratiques et respectueuses
des droits de l'homme nous partagent en
outre la langue française avec nos
homologues sur tous les continents
ces mêmes idéaux le président de la
république a établi des priorités pour
conduire la politique de la nation
l'économie bien sûr pour relancer
l'emploi le défi climatique mais
également la francophonie la
francophonie richesse qui contribue au
rayonnement de notre pays il nous faut
donc construire dans cet espace
francophone les conditions d'une société
plus juste et plus égalitaire
le président de la république a
d'ailleurs développé cette thématique au
sommet des chefs d'états kinshasa et
juste avant il s'était merveille et
devant l'assemblée nationale du sénégal
où sont élus aujourd'hui autant de
femmes que d'hommes
de quoi rêver nous avons en commun une
préoccupation la situation des femmes
dans tous ces pays de l'espace
francophone et particulièrement les
violences qui leur sont faites dans
certains territoires et où la régression
des droits qu'elles subissent ou
craignent de subir dans d'autres ainsi
les femmes du mali ont vécu une
situation infernale dans le nord de leur
pays jusqu'à l'arrivée de nos soldats
reconnaissante au président de la
république qui a pris la décision qui
s'imposait afin de rendre à ce pays
l'autonomie et la sérénité qui lui sont
chers nous le voyons bien la
francophonie ce n'est pas seulement une
en commune c'est aussi un ensemble de
valeurs et d'idéaux qu'il nous faut
promouvoir
je sais combien madame la ministre vous
êtes préoccupé par les difficultés
particulières des femmes dans cet espace
et vous l'avez montré en vous rendant à
goma rencontré ces femmes victimes de
viols arme de guerre dans le territoire
du kivu
lorsque je vous ai rencontrés à kinshasa
chacun sait que la condition des femmes
est un des révélateurs grossissant de la
situation du pays dans lequel elles
vivent
chaque année nous célébrons la journée
de la francophonie le 20 mars
ma question est simple donc madame la
ministre quel est votre programme
d'activités pour cette journée cette
année
quelles initiatives mettez-vous en place
afin de promouvoir la francophonie et
les droits des femmes dans notre pays et
dans cet espace je vous remercie
merci la parole aux femmes adorent
diamino bangui le ministre chargé de la
francophonie monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice merci pour votre
question je connais vos combats pour la
cause des femmes
et permettez moi de les saluer j'ai
décidé d'organiser le 20 mars à paris
date de la journée internationale de la
francophonie
le premier forum mondial des femmes
francophones
cette décision est née d'un état
d'urgence inacceptable avec les valeurs
d'égalité de solidarité que porte la
francophonie c'est bien dans l'espace
francophone que les femmes sont les
premières victimes des conflits armés
c'est bien dans l'espace francophone que
des escadrons de la mort des groupes
armés rebelles en rdc au nord kivu ont
programmé le viol de milliers de femmes
devenues butin de guerre
c'est bien dans l'espace francophone
qu'un véritable génocide au féminin
s'est déroulé depuis des mois dans un
silence assourdissant
c'est bien dans l'espace francophone en
tunisie au mali en egypte que les acquis
des femmes sont en régression
c'est pour toutes ces raisons que j'ai
promis de porter la parole sur la
violation de leurs droits
le 20 mars prochain à paris 400 femmes
venues des 77 pays de l'est
espace francophone dont beaucoup d'entre
elles portent les stigmates de leurs
droits bafoués viendront faire entendre
leur voix pour le respect de leur droit
à la dignité et à l'égalité à
l'intégrité de leur identité
ce forum portera les fondations d'un
nouveau statut des femmes francophones
et la défense de leurs droits
partout ils sont menacés aux côtés de
l'onef je souhaite que la france un sur
un véritable plan d'action pour femmes
et francophonie
ce sont ces objectifs que je porterai
devant les institutions de la
francophonie et auprès des états qui la
composent
c'est toute l'ambition de ce premier
forum premier forum mondial de femmes et
francophonie
je vous en remercie merci
la parole est à présent monsieur
philippe dominati pour le groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire
mais chez le président mesdames et
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse initialement à monsieur le
premier ministre puisque c'est lui qui
devra arbitrer dans quelques jours le
financement de la société d'état du
grand paris mais je suis très satisfait
madame le ministre puisque vous avez été
quelques jours élus de paris qu'il vous
ait dizainier pour me répondre
le concept du grand paris a été
développé par nicolas sarkozy pour faire
en sorte que la métropole parisienne
francilienne garde son rang dans le
monde
et deuxièmement pour résoudre un
problème immédiat urgent la congestion
des transports en ile de france
mais l'alternance a eu lieu
vous détenez maintenant désormais tous
les pouvoirs le pouvoir national le
pouvoir régional le pouvoir communal
et que se passe-t-il que se passe-t-il
quand nous apprenons que paris a perdu 4
places
en ce qui concerne l'attractivité dans
le monde en 2012 en accueillant
seulement 105 entreprises étrangères au
lieu de 150 se passe rien que se
passe-t-il quand nous apprenons que le
chômage augmentait de
6 5% un an et de 15% pour les plus de 50
ans rien que se passe-t-il quand nous
apprenons qu'un groupe étranger va
mettre en vente la bourse de paris
aucune déclaration évidemment il ya
quelques bisbilles il ya la contestation
du président du conseil régional d'île
de france à l'égard du maire de paris
concernant la politique de bureau
d'ailleurs je crois madame la ministre
que vous êtes pour la taxation des
bureaux vacants
il y a le ministre de l'intérieur qui
tacle le maire de paris quand les berges
sur scène en combres économiquement et
et s'étonne du coût économique de cette
décision
il ya des bisbilles entre les verts et
la majorité socialiste sur le passe
navigo ou sur le financement de tels ou
tels organismes de transport
pourtant il reste 9 milliards à trouver
pour améliorer les transports en ile de
france et l'état ne paye rien ce sont
les entreprises d'île de france qui paye
45 % du coût global
ce sont les entreprises d'ile-de-france
qui pèse 75 % du coût de fonctionnement
et le reste ce sont les contribuables
avec un impôt spécifique
la taxe d'équipement un impôt spécifique
c'est 20% du cours et donc voilà qu'on
apprend que de nouvelles sources de
financement sont attendus que le premier
ministre va trancher est-ce qu'il va
demander une augmentation des impôts aux
parisiens et aux franciliens
est-ce qu'il va demander une
augmentation des impôts aux entreprises
parce que l'activité économique est trop
forte dans notre région
c'est cette question que je demande je
vous demande d engagement des
engagements clairs n'augmente pas les
impôts ne taxait pas les entreprises et
prenez vos responsabilités vous voulez
que l'etac commandes bien que l'état
paye merci la parole est à madame cécile
duflot ministre de l'égalité des
territoires et du logement
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur dominati c'est
assez original votre façon de présenter
ce dossier parce que si
le dossier du grand paris express a une
spécificité c'est qu'il a fait un moment
un grand consensus à la fois sur ses
modalités de financement et sur son
projet grand consensus pour une raison
assez désagréable finalement c'est qu'il
avait été largement sous-évalué quand je
dis largement c'est qu'il manquait 10
milliards 10 milliards qui n'avait pas
été évalué initialement 10 milliards
alors que ce projet avait a suscité une
attente considérable chez les
franciliens 10 milliards alors qu'il est
absolument nécessaire y compris pour
l'activité des entreprises ferroviaires
françaises que nous lancions ce dossier
voilà pourquoi le choix du gouvernement
a été de travailler sur un roe
dimensionnement de ce projet pour faire
baisser son coût final de 30 milliards
sur les moyens de mobiliser différentes
sources de financement pour réussir à
financer l'ensemble de choc de ce projet
pour répondre aux attentes des élus de
toutes les collectivités locales et de
toutes les couleurs politiques croyait
bien que ce qui unit un certain nombre
d'élus autour de ce projet c'est la
nécessité de répondre aux besoins de
déplacement des franciliens mais aussi
de répondre aux futurs besoins de
déplacements la saturation de certaines
lignes en ile de france est aujourd'hui
identifiez-vous faisait référence aux
taxes affectées à la société du grand
paris
ce sont des taxes qui ont été décidées
par le précédent gouvernement et votée
par le sénat et par l'assemblée
nationale pour financer ce projet comme
ce qu'il se passe dans les autres pays
du monde il est nécessaire évidemment
que tout le monde apporte une part
l'état et ce sera fait le premier
ministre est engagé pour les besoins en
dotation de la société du grand paris
mais également que des contributions qui
permettent de financer ce projet qui
sera phase et dans le temps soit faite
évidemment que l'équation est compliquée
quand on fait la promesse comme la phase
précédant le précédent gouvernement de
porter un projet à 20 milliards d'euros
alors qu'il vaut 30 milliards il est
certain qu'on laisse une situation qui
est extrêmement désagréable à gérer
néanmoins et parce que nous avons la
volonté de tenir cette promesse qui a
été faite de l'état et qu'il y ait une
continuité des engagements le
gouvernement et l'ensemble des
collectivités locales dont la région
ile-de-france dont l'ensemble des
départements continuent de travailler
sur ce dossier le premier ministre
annoncera le 6 mars
le scénario qu'il est possible de faire
pour répondre
à une attente qui se fait chaque jour de
plus en plus criante merci mes chers
collègues nous en avons fini avec des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h15 pour le débat sur le
développement dans les relations
nord-sud
voilà pour cette séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement on se
retrouve tout de suite avec nos invités
pour refaire cette séance